We have a voicemail number and that number
is two one nine two David P..
We got a voicemail from the Eggman with a
prediction for twenty twenty four.
He wants to bet people about this.
Take a listen to what he had to say.
Hey, Dave, I like to bet on politics and I
won on this presidential election, even though
I'm not getting paid by the schmuck who owes
me because he thinks, you know, Trump is going
to win in court anyway.
I've got a bet for you or for any of your
listeners.
Yeah, my pillow.
Twenty for my window.
My pillow.
Twenty twenty four is going to run in twenty
twenty four.
It's not going to win.
He's not going to get nominated at all, but
he's going to be one of the morons in the
beginning.
OK, anybody want to take you up on that bet.
I'll bet anything.
I guarantee you this guy is going to run for
political office president brother.
OK, I don't think Eggman is wrong.
I think that.
So if you don't know who Eggman is talking
about, there's this guy, Mike Lyndell from
the company, my pillow.
They sell pillows via television commercials.
He is a big Trump supporter, I believe he
said Trump was a gift from God or something
along those lines.
He was put front and center at some of these
early coronavirus press events as someone
who was going to be making masks and contributing
to the effort in some way, shape or form,
et cetera, et cetera, guys completely out
of his mind.
And he recently donated a bunch of money to
Kyle Rittenhouse is bail to two million dollars
bail money, as we discussed yesterday on the
bonus show.
And Airmen's idea is that he may actually
run for president.
I don't think that that that's out of whack.
It wouldn't be unlike a pizza man, Herman
Cain, who has since departed this Earth due
to coronavirus.
It wouldn't be like some of these other kind
of edge case type candidates who are trying
to get some publicity.
I mean, listen, that's kind of how it started
with Trump.
We don't we don't really believe Trump thought
he was going to win or was even interested
in winning early, quite quite frankly.
But I think AGYEMAN may be on to something.
I would be completely unsurprised if Mike
Lyndell does run for president.
I agree with Egemen.
I don't think he would win a curious to hear
from you.
If anybody is interested in betting with Ackman,
I guess get in touch with him on the bonus
show today.
There is this viral video that has been going
around of a trumpet, a vile trumpet that deliberately
sort of like powerfully exhaling on people
outside a Trump golf club, and he has now
been charged with simple assault for that.
I guess the idea, of course, was to scare
someone that he may be trying to give them
the virus.
We are going to talk about the reaction from
the oil industry to Joe Biden.
This issue of oil was a big issue during the
campaign and a big topic for Donald Trump
during his rallies.
And we are also going to talk about the surge
in cannabis related stocks in the market as
a result of Joe Biden winning.
And we'll talk about what we might actually
see in terms of legalization, decriminalization
during a Biden administration.
Very, very there are dramatically different
views as to what Joe Biden is expected to
do, if anything, on decriminalization and
legalization.
And we'll be discussing that on today's bonus
show.
Two ways to get instant access to the bonus
No.
One, very simple, the preferred way get a
membership at join Pakman.
Dotcom takes under a minute.
Very, very strong way to get access to the
bonus show.
Other alternative become a patron at Patreon
dot com slash David Pakman show.
We'll speak to you then.